foreign
[Music]
should be in school but has been forced
to give up his studies and work his
family were alive for their basic needs
on the money he earns selling vegetables
at the market
I was in the ninth grade but I stopped
going to school so I can work hard to
provide for my family to cover our daily
expenses I am trying to do my best to
see what God provides of course I would
rather be in school than working but
what can we do someone has to support
the family
United Nations says there are around 3
million children who cannot go to school
in Yemen
the near-decade-long war has forced many
yemenis to take their children out of
school so they can work and help ease
the financial pressure the millions of
families face every day
the UN says nearly 3 000 schools have
been either completely or partially
destroyed and more than a quarter
enclosed
the main reason the students dropping
out is because of difficulties there's
so many things we tried like speeding up
the educational process and supporting
the students financially so they can go
back to school but these efforts have
failed another reason we keep failing is
the financial situation of the teachers
has been a teacher for 30 years his
salary is not enough to cover his
family's needs the average wage for a
teacher in Yemen is now less than 60
dollars a month and it was almost seven
times that amount before the war
as is the case for many people working
in the public sector teachers salaries
are rarely paid on time and often not at
all
as teachers we're living in very
difficult times extremely difficult we
cannot even handle our basic daily
expenses and our family's needs mainly
because of the war every year Rising
costs mean the salary depreciate more
this year our wages have hits rock
bottom
teachers have taken to the streets in
protest
raise your voices loud and clear they
chant
stopping our salaries means our demise
Charles Stratford house
[Music]
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera